all right well I'd like to welcome
everyone to the Center for American
Progress my name is melody Barnes and I
am thrilled that you're here and I am
definitely thrilled that we have Andy
Stern here to talk to us about his new
new book a country that works and first
I'd just like you to help me join and
thank Andy for being here as I was
reading the book I was thinking about
the fact that often when you think about
great leaders people who take on
movements who really do movement
building that often usually about the
age of three they have a plan for their
lives
you know they're going to be president
of their kindergarten and they go on to
be the president of their class that in
college and it's all really mapped out
and in reading Andy's book what you find
out is that isn't exactly true with Andy
in fact when he was 23 he says that he
stumbled into a union meeting and for
the pizza and and accidentally became
the assistant district shop steward of
the union and his career in labor really
started at that point and he went on
from there and a couple of decades later
became the president of SEIU in 1996 and
now leads a movement of almost 2 million
janitors and nurses and home health care
workers and others which is really a
tremendous tremendous piece of work and
what you've done for our country has
really been quite amazing and I think it
also speaks to the fact that even if you
don't necessarily have a plan for your
life at the age of 3 often life has a
plan for you and Andy has certainly
dedicated his life to improving a lot of
those who don't necessarily have a voice
and and we really want to thank him for
that
but his work really goes beyond just
that of the u.s. borders he's also now
doing an incredible job of trying to
form coops
with unions and labor movements overseas
and I hope we have an opportunity to
talk about that a little bit this
afternoon as well and many have credited
him for his work he's been described as
a quote new breed of union boss and a
maverick by Barbara Ehrenreich who many
of you know because of her work and her
authorship of the book Nikhil
and other pieces of work and she also
describes him as a bold vision that's
having a bold vision for reform and a
man who has devoted his life to the
struggle for a better deal for America's
working people and I think that Andy
realizes what so many of us realize that
in order to confront the issues of the
21st century and the global issues and
and multinational corporations and the
work that's needed for America's workers
that you really have to have a big
vision so that's what we want to talk
about today and thank you for being here
before we start to talk about some of
the more specific issues I want to ask
you a question that I thought about as I
was reading your book and just give you
an opportunity to tell us a little bit
about your vision and what you were
thinking about when you wrote the book
because it seemed to me that I mean
you've been leading a growing movement
at SEIU you've really helped to build it
from about a million people to almost
two million about 1.8 million people
today you led the effort that gave birth
to the change to win coalition that
you've initiated historic partnerships
with business leaders and others and
sectors where people thought that that
wasn't necessarily possible you have
this vision for an international
cooperative with all that on your plate
what led you to write a country that
works and what is it that you are hoping
to achieve with the book well for all of
those big ideas what led me to write
this book was people like Marvin Parker
and a Marvis the security officer in New
York City he's worked there for nine
years after nine years of guarding you
know multi-million if not billion dollar
buildings Marvin makes seven dollars an
hour he got one raise of 25 cents but
more importantly Marvin has his big
infection in his eye and he can't afford
to go to the doctor he says if he goes
to the doctor he can't afford to buy the
medicine and then to add insult to
injury he has no sick leaves who would
have to lose a day's pay I think about
Marvin I think about all the kids who
went to college from 2001 to 2004 did
everything America asked them to do and
now they saw a 5 percent decrease in
their real earnings in the last four
years and I think about how in 2005 more
women went bankrupt than graduated
college
I wrote this book for all of them and
for a country I love this country I
think America is a gift and its greatest
gift was the American Dream but just
people for generation after generation
came to these shores all they wanted to
do was work hard and hope their work
would be valued and rewarded but even
more importantly they had this dream
that their kid would do better than they
would and I am sad that 52% of American
parents now think their kids are gonna
do worse than they are and the facts are
starting to prove them right so that's
not the America I want it's not the
America we need and it's time for
Americans to come together and realize
the world has changed and we need a plan
absolutely actually I want to pick up on
something you mentioned in terms of
talking about the American dream and
Marvin and other people like him because
I think the American dream is something
that more and more Americans are
questioning is something that I think is
inherently a part of our spirit and the
spirit of our country but it's something
that people are starting to question
even as they're desperately trying to
hang on to it you talked about the 52%
of Americans who think that they won't
be able to achieve that they're the 47%
of middle-income Americans who think as
hard as I try I'm not going to be able
to get ahead and you point out in your
book that you know we've gone through
civil wars and world wars we've had 43
different presidents we've had natural
disasters you know a number of
calamities and at the same time we've
really held on to this concept of the
American dream but now we're struggling
with it you also point out that part of
the problem seems to be that as we talk
about the American dream
we're not even talking about it in the
right way today that we can't have a
serious conversation about solutions we
can't have a serious conversation about
the problem until we actually measure
what's going on with middle income
workers in the appropriate way unless we
have the right Economic Security
indicators can you talk to us a little
bit more about what it is you think that
we need to put forth so that we can even
start this conversation appropriately I
mean I think measurement matters I mean
just think about today we now see the
stock market is that record high
corporate profits are the greatest share
of national income of any time in
history and wages at the same time or at
the
and so people are going and watching the
television and saying well if the
economy's growing and if the stock
markets rising why do I feel so squeezed
and the truth is cap and SEIU just did a
whole report and index a new index that
really looks apart where our middle
class people now can they sustain a loss
of a job a medical emergency of like
3,300 dollars and the truth is less and
less of them are able to do it and you
know it was an incredible amount of work
to develop the statistics but now we can
really measure for the first time what
is happening to people in the middle
class
do they have three months worth of
savings is it getting better or worse
and I think it's a real contribution to
start the conversations from some facts
and do you think we're talking about
something brand brand new I mean right
now they're a set of indicators you turn
on your evening news and you know what
you hear about your about GDP and a
whole range of other factors how do you
think that we can move this kind of
indices indicator into popular culture
into the policy-making culture into the
economic culture and conversation of our
country one things I'm glad about is on
that cap you know because it is really
the first institution that I know of
that's focused on working Americans that
actually has the ability to start to
begin to put this into the mainstream I
think it's up to all of us to try to
take this information and start a very
different conversation in America we you
know we're not going to drive into the
future looking in the rearview mirror we
can't be diverted by well maybe the
market will solve the problem maybe
trade will solve the problem you know
maybe education will solve the problem
the problem is getting worse and the
truth is we now have a way to measure it
to talk about it and I think we need to
carry it into the popular culture well
as we have that conversation and one I
think Americans and others people around
the world are desperate to have I think
about something else that I read in your
book you you say in your book economic
growth increased productivity and rising
profits translated in to improve living
standards for most Americans we prosper
together when the market wasn't working
effectively two primary forces
intervened to help the market distribute
gains relatively equally the government
and labor unions in fact it's
your argument that unions not only work
for workers but they also work for
business and at the same time unions can
be a strong voice for employees they
don't have to be the adversaries of
employers I think that's a new vision
that's a new way of thinking about labor
unions and certainly it isn't one that
people necessarily think about when they
talk about the story of labor unions and
I wanted to get you have you talked to
us a little bit about some of the
innovative ways that you as a union
leader have reached out to businesses to
try and form partnerships to bring about
the American dream for some of the
lowest paid workers in the country the
janitors and home health care workers
that you represent well first of all I
think it's important for unions to
recognize we're in the 21st century you
know this is not the industrial economy
it's not the 1930s and that our
employers also live in a very
competitive world in some cases a
globally competitive world so we have to
act and think differently we can't start
from the premise we're going to create
problems for our employers because
somehow they're not acting appropriately
and really have to think about how do we
solve problems how do we add value in
our relationship so we look at janitors
in New York New Jersey or Philadelphia
and we say you know we could organize
one employer and we could raise their
wages and then that employer would be
less competitive and someone would
underbid him and the cycle would begin
again or we could talk to all the
employers about how do we stabilize
employment you know how do we find a way
to maybe take some of their costs that
they would have to pay as a small
employer off of them and pull them
together whether it's for training or
health care or retirement so then the
end the competition isn't about who pays
the lease but about who can manage
better who's technologically more
proficient you know who can do better
sales in terms of their business
products and so we're trying to change
the basis of competition in a way that
employers aren't negatively impacted
we've gone to our nursing home employers
and say you know so much of your money
comes from the government you know and
we should go to the government together
and talk about how we can fund the
nursing homes better but we also need to
talk about how we can fund homecare
better because in the end people don't
want to be in nursing homes they want to
be in their home and so we need to
create a system that doesn't say we're
going to trap you in an institution but
where you get the
say there's no place like home and at
the same time we say to the nursing home
employers and we want some of this money
to go to improve staffing and quality at
the bedside because we want people who
go to nursing homes our patients to be
treated decently and yes you know if
there's more money the workers will do
better and you'll do better as well but
it it's the whole package of improving
service and quality we have the largest
labor management partnership with Kaiser
Permanente in the history of the service
sector and what's happened where we used
to have strikes all the time we now have
a collaboration a partnership at the
bedside all of a sudden Kaiser is seen
it's its outcomes dramatically improve
its cost in terms of lost wages for
injuries you know begin to decrease so
partnerships work and I just think you
know people ask unions to reinvent
themselves and I think it was really
important and we tried hard now in SEIU
to do so it's now time business
reinvents themselves and realized they
have a responsibility to their workers
into their country as well and I think
that's the discussion we all need to
have well I want to talk about that a
little bit more because you're talking
about business needing to reinvent
itself and you're also talking about the
healthcare industry and the healthcare
problem and I think what you did
recently was really interesting and I
want to talk about the response that you
got I don't know how many of you saw an
op-ed that Andy wrote called a horse and
was it a horse and buggy health horse
and buggy health coverage and in that
op-ed you said I'm going to send a
letter today this was a couple of months
ago I'm going to send a letter today to
the CEOs of all the fortune 500
companies and ask them to join me and
others health care professionals unions
to try and press for change in terms of
health care in America you sent the
letter what kind of response are you
getting is business reinventing itself
in this particular context well on one
hand I think the response has been much
better than I ever would expect it I
mean major CEOs major companies have
responded and said you know Steve Bird
from Safeway recently said I could have
written that editorial you know other
people have said you know you're really
right on target but let me just explain
two problems one is we have to do this
because America is not going to compete
in a global economy where were the only
country in the world major industrial
company country who puts the price of
healthcare in the
cost of our product and competitors
don't I mean that is just terrible
business proposition for a global
economy so this is an economic
consideration as well as a moral one and
I just think sometimes people don't
appreciate this is not our fathers and
grandfathers economy it's not a one
lifetime and economy the New Deal is as
far today you know as we are as the
civil war was from the New Deal
I mean and I sure Franklin Roosevelt
admired Abraham Lincoln but he didn't
build an economy and we can't build an
economy simply upon and a policy isn't
an industrial era that's what the health
care system was the relic of an
industrial era it's a horse and buggy
situation in the global economy so one
of the employers say yes they want to do
something but here's what bothers me and
just the concerns me I mean here are
people who've conquered the internet
they've mapped the genome you know they
become global corporations but so few of
them are ready to go publicly out and
say no this employer-based health care
system really doesn't work for us it's
not the right thing for America and more
importantly 46 million people don't have
any health care at all we should do
something different and so the response
privately has been good I think the
question right now is are we didn't get
a group of CEOs you know who come
forward to serve their country as well
as serve I think their long-term
business interest well just kind of
drilling down on that a little bit more
that I don't want to characterize it go
well I'll tell you what I was thinking
because the culture of fear the culture
of what prevents business leaders who
are privately saying this is something
that's important this is something we
ought to do it's important for my bottom
line as a business owner what's
preventing them for pressing for change
in Washington and how do we go about
changing that how do we go about
changing the environment in the climate
so that business leaders can join with
you and others and trying to accomplish
the change that's really necessary well
first of all I think we all have to
think of ourselves as Americans I think
we have to think about we're on Team USA
in a very competitive moment of history
I mean China will be the first economic
competitor that has a greater economy
than we do in the next 15 or 20 years so
we need a plan and the problem is that
business leaders I think first of all
feel the pressures of just running a
company but also they feel the
retaliation possibilities of an
administration
who doesn't really tolerate you know a
lot of differences of opinions in the
corporate community we have people who
are worried that their shareholders or
their stakeholders or their suppliers
are somehow gonna punish them but this
is about leadership I mean we can't say
that we care about our kids and our
grandkids or we can't say we care about
Marvin you know and then not have the
courage to step forward at a time when
America needs leadership I want to go
back to health care again in a minute
but while we're talking about you
mentioned China and we're talking about
globalization and and international
efforts I want you to talk a little bit
about what you described in your book in
terms of your efforts to think beyond
the shores of the United States what
you're doing to try and achieve a global
union movement and what that looks like
and also what tensions exist as you're
thinking about organizing and
representing US workers when at the same
time you're thinking about workers
overseas where their needs sometimes
their mutual goals but at the same times
they're their needs may diverge their
desires may diverge at Point I used to
say that you know workers of the world
unite you know as a political struggle
and a political ideology and now it's
just a way that people need to do their
work I mean today as we speak workers in
China workers in India workers in Mexico
Canada the United States Korea Brazil
are all waking up and going to work at
Walmart they all have least got as their
employer they're not interested
necessarily about what's Americans
foreign policy they're interested about
their job and their family in Brazil
just like they are in the United States
and so all of a sudden when you go to
China you don't have to talk about some
of the same issues that we've talked
about for centuries you can talk about
how two workers of the world who work
for the same companies joined together
to help change their lives and so I
think we're having a very different
conversation capital went global trade
went global companies went global
and how can unions stay local or
national at the same time it makes no
sense and so the question that is how do
we get there and and what makes sense so
far is to talk to people who work in the
same industries and the same companies
know about how we can work together and
so right now I never thought I'd say we
have staff of ours working in nine
different countries
now we are working with solid artists
like Miles's Union about organizing
security workers for the same company
that were organized in Australian in
South Africa and just want to strike in
Indonesia so you're watching the
emergence of people beginning to work
together and I think the next step is we
need to be in the same organization and
what form of shape and that takes I
don't know there are huge cultural
issues there huge political issues
because we don't want to intervene in
people's you know internal national
political questions but when it comes to
the employer you put all these workers
in the same room and other than the
language barriers you would think you
know they all you know came from the
same worksite because they're all have
the same problems and all have the same
employer so I think that's one huge
thing and there are tensions I mean the
tensions are people say but if you are
gonna let jobs go overseas then all of a
sudden you're not pro-american and and I
do think there's been huge problems with
our trade policies and I think we need
to correct though but globalization is
going to work its way through in some
way shape or form and the question is
are our workers are gonna benefit can we
raise wages everywhere you know and can
we create a new paradigm in terms of
global unionism and I think we can and
just out of curiosity in terms of your
membership I mean what what do you hear
from them as you talk about this effort
I was so scared of our convention when
we talked about building a global union
and people like got out of their seats
in a second because what I don't
appreciate is so many of our members are
immigrants they come from these
countries you know so you go to London
to organize the janitor where we've been
doing it and they look exactly like the
workers in New York City you know
they're immigrants from South America or
from African countries you know working
in the tubes of London and working in
the apartment houses of New York City
and so for our workers they actually get
it faster people appreciate that they're
living in a global world they expect to
work hard they want their work to be you
know valued and rewarded but they not
saying less erect barriers and pretend
that America you know can exist in on
its own it can't but how we do that I
think is really the question that we
need to deal with in our country well
first of all I just want to give the
audience a heads up in a couple of
minutes I'll turn to you so if you have
questions for Andy start thinking about
them so we'll spend a little bit of time
doing that but before we go to the
audience they do want to ask you
questions about health care mean a few
more questions about health care we've
been talking about the American Dream
and the idea of mobility and recently I
guess it was this past April we at the
center had a paper commissioned for us
as part of our mobility work by
Professor Tom Hertz of American
University he talks about mobility some
of the things that we were mentioning
how a mobility it's really there's
become a hardening within our country
and people have the the inability of
people to move from one level to the
next I guess if you're in sixty percent
of people won't be able or the bottom
sixty percent of those that the income
ladder will only have a 2 percent chance
of getting to the upper end of the
income ladder and one of the major
indicators of whether or not people are
going to have intergenerational mobility
is healthcare it's at the top of the
list of concerns for your members you're
interested in issues of costs you're
interested in issues of quality and cost
for both consumers and for for business
owners so given just how important it is
given what you've described in terms of
it's important in terms of corporate
competitiveness what do you think it's
going to take to really not only start
the conversation but as you said in your
book not just have this endless debate
around health care reform but start the
conversation and get us to a point we
can actually put real reform on the
table and get something passed into law
I mean yeah I think the winds have
changed you know that blow countries in
different directions come from a series
of places no one is leadership and and I
think the business community has been
lacking and needs to step forward
because this is not again a moral
question it's now an economic one and I
think the debate would clearly shift in
Washington DC if ten or fifteen major
CEOs said the employer system is dead
America needs a basic universal plan
doesn't have to be Canadian or
Scandinavian it can be American you know
we can learn from the best of around the
world but we need to do it now if
America is going to compete I think that
would fundamentally change things I
think people running for president or
Senate or other offices strictly focused
on health care and then winning would be
a huge opportunity in Harris Wofford you
know had his famous campaign saying if
you know if you're entitled to a lawyer
you know why isn't every American
entitled to a doctor and I think his
victory you know help President Clinton
and people feel there was an appetite
for change in the country and you know I
think we need Democrats and Republicans
did not talk about incremental change
but fundamental change we should stop
tinkering around the edges it that
hasn't worked and really go to the heart
of the matter and so I think it's about
leadership and I think the business
community is important and it's also
about individuals I mean we need to lift
our voices as Americans and say we're
done with this antiquated health care
system I cannot keep looking at these
health care bills I don't want to fill
that another set of forms that my doctor
that I filled out last week there's no
electronic medical records I want to
know whether this doctor does good or
bad health care I want to know the
outcomes you know I want to know the
cost not because I want to have an HSA
because I want to have some opportunity
to make some decent choices so I I think
we're at the tipping point the question
is are enough of us going to get on the
other side to tip it over and I think
we're getting very very close and what's
so amazing is the work that we again our
organizations have done together around
the research on this issue and we know
well over 80% of American people want
this kind of change that includes
conservatives moderates progressives so
it's incredible that we're I thought
that I thought the report that capita
yeah you did about where are Americans
on this issue was was just so
demonstrative that we are at a different
moment that people are looking for
leadership and they're just not finding
and that people are willing to be very
open minded and practical about the
solutions you know and I think that
organizations like ours will see you
know in in the next year start to have
some debates in Iowa and Nevada New
Hampshire with Democrats and Republicans
and others trying to ask them what are
you going to do about health care how
are you going to pay for it and how are
you going to keep America competitive
and if this is the moment that the
American people want this kind of change
and if even if it's privately said
business leaders want this kind of
change and we're talking about something
that's big and comprehensive Universal
what do you say to those people who are
saying well we shouldn't let the perfect
be the enemy of the good
you know what about incremental change
why why not just take it
step at a time because I think we're
figuring it out we can't fix the system
by incremental change you know first of
all anything we fix politically can be
undone politically I thought it was
really sad to see that we actually have
less children in short for the first
time this year in the last several years
we have made so much progress with chip
you know an increasing health care
coverage now we're going again in the
wrong direction so I think the enemy
should not be perfect of the good in
terms of what's our universal system I
think we have to be very flexible about
how we get to a basic benefit but I
don't think incremental change is going
to be enough I just don't think we can
fix the system that way and get the cost
savings as well as to get the outcomes
we're really looking for and does that
demand that for those of us pushing for
big-picture change that we be bolder not
only with those who oppose the idea but
also with our friends to try and move
push the entire movement I think it's
really important that we say to people
now this is the moment we you get a
chance to act upon why most people ran
for office you know they didn't run just
a hold office they ran to do something
will do something American people want
you to do something the business
community wants you to do something this
is a time where we all have to find the
courage inside of us to step up and I
think we're going to find a huge
audience for change if we're practical
if we're principled if we don't let the
perfect be the enemy of the good
there is a huge audience waiting for
leaders well thank you I don't want to
monopolize you enjoying the conversation
but I do want to open the floor to find
out if others here have questions that
they'd like to ask Andy about these
issues or any others that you have on
your mind please raise your hand and
also identify yourself and Michael will
bring the microphone by you talked a bit
there about the inadequacy of
incremental change and you talked a bit
also about how the employer system is a
dad and yet a variety of groups some
funded by SEIU some not are trying to
get companies like Walmart and so forth
to enter into fair share agreements
which are rather incremental they just
put a little bit more money towards
healthcare for the payroll and they
reinforce the employer base system at
what level is attempting to
make the goalpost what type of health
care Walmart itself will offer at what
level is that actually contradictory or
harmful to the goal of moving health
care out of the employer mandate
entirely I think it's fair to say that
intellectually you know if you put this
on an intellectual argument you could
argue it's contradictory I think
practically though we cannot let the
largest employer in the world you know
get away from asking me and Marvin to
pay for their workers health care plan
and I think the fact that we've put so
much pressure on them you know had Lee
Scott say on Charlie Rose the other
night you know maybe business and labor
should get together and build a new
healthcare system so I think
strategically it's working
intellectually clearly there's some
contradictions another question hi Paul
Jameson looking at the numbers about
wages being stagnant it occurs to me
that what must be happening is that big
businesses revenue must be staying it as
well and I'm not seeing an analysis of
saying well your profits are going up
but your revenues must not be and
profits they only be caught cut so much
cost can only be cut so much what if you
said to them you know look your revenues
are not going to go up until it
everybody gets a wage an increase in
their profit center and their and their
income and then I have a stack tactical
question about the the newspaper this
morning about the nurses being deemed as
supervisors is it a plausible strategy
that go to Congress assuming that it
changes and say why don't you just
change the definition of supervisor so
first of all I'm not an economist and
there are plenty in the room so I get
nervous answering this question but I
think revenues are going way up you know
in corporations it's just how the money
is being distributed you know this is
the good news for America we're not
Raimondo we're not Bosnia you know we
have an enormous amount of growing
wealth in our country and yet it's not
being shared fairly anymore between the
workers the shareholders and the people
that helped create it and so that is our
fundamental question it's not growth its
distribution that as Melanie said you
know there are two ways that we
distributed actually three ways we've
distributed wealth in this country the
first was the market and for a while for
a long period of time you know a rising
tide raised all boats you know more
equitably you know and now it's just
raising the luxury liners and so we've
seen the market become unhinged as
people say you know where the growth in
productivity and the growth in profits
is not providing a growth in wages and
economists don't know what to do because
they've never seen it before and it's a
problem you know then we have government
which can distribute wealth and this
government is distributing wealth it's
just distributing it upward you know it
has a conscious effort to redistribute
wealth to a smaller and smaller group of
people and then of these things called
unions which regardless of what you
think about ideologically you know can
distribute wealth you know more
equitably inside firms doesn't require
the government's involvement in
everything we do you know and in terms
of the supervisor case it was just a
tragedy that more and more people have
less and less rights in America I mean
the nature of work has changed 25% of
all American workers are now contingent
meaning they don't have a full-time
employer anymore you know we have all
kinds of people that are becoming more
and more independent contractors then we
have people that are excluded from laws
because their farm workers or their
domestic workers or and now what we have
is people that go to work every day into
a minimal amount of work as a supervisor
being excluded for having any right and
here's the the risk nurses who don't
feel comfortable about speaking out
about what they see at the bedside what
they want to tell a patient you know
about their parents health or their
needs because somehow now they're a
supervisor and they could necessarily be
fired at will you know all of a sudden
our could've feel the same freedom to
pride of quality care so it's much
bigger question than just are we
limiting the number of people who have
rights in this country which we are more
and more every day sadly it's also about
why in the world do we want to keep
people quiet who we count on you know to
speak out and help us navigate our way
through our parents and our friends and
our families illness other questions
mark Bruin burger press associates Andy
epic I've asked you this before what
gives you hope that the business side of
the ledger is going to respond
positively the response with possibly
the exception that the gentleman from
Safeway has been fine let's get rid of
health care costs let's get rid of the
workers and shove it on to them and
that's just one example I mean I say a
number of things you know a change in
Congress might give me hope because I
think people respond to the realities of
the times and I think that would be you
know hopeful but I also think you know
there are a lot of people who run
companies and I should be the last one
in the world who says this you know who
actually do care about their country who
do care about their workers you know and
yet have not stepped forward about this
and I think when you begin to frame this
as an economic question it somewhat
empowers them to step forward because no
one's paying them to be quote moral
leaders they're make you know paying
them to quote make money for the
shareholders but all of a sudden we are
talking about how we're gonna make money
for the shareholders and how we're gonna
you know rein in excess of health care
costs so maybe it's just some
conversations I've had and maybe I'll
turn out to be completely wrong but I
think there's a growing sense on the
part of American business leaders
something is fundamentally wrong in
general in our country that the gap
between the rich and the poor as Alan
Greenspan is even saying is growing so
wide and so fast it threatens democratic
capitalism Bob Rubens talking about the
lack of broad-based growth warren
buffett now says the poor are not
benefitting by a growing economy I think
people know something's wrong and health
care is the most obvious self-interested
place to begin to solve this problem
because it's a national problem that has
benefit for everybody and I would
imagine some of your work though this
you know this is kind of the big one or
one of the big ones but some of your
other work work with CEOs and business
would indicate that there is a light you
know there the door is cracked and the
opportunity to move through it exists
yeah I think if there was a you know
more of a sense that this was the time
in a public way
so more CEOs were stepping forward or
political leaders we're really saying
now is the time I think you could rally
it's unlikely that the union leader is
gonna rally the CEOs for this
for this solution but you know you see a
guy like Howard Schultz from Starbucks
who pays more for coffee being for
healthcare than he pays for coffee beans
or you understand that CEOs and
corporations are spending more on health
care than they're making in profits
every year and you say this is just
unsustainable in its current form and
then Howard Schultz comes to Washington
as he said in his newspaper or magazine
article says he's so frustrated you know
by the lack of vision around here and I
think it's people like Howard Schultz
and I think it's you know people like
politicians who it's their moment you
know and I'm pleased to hear that people
like Barack Obama and Rod and wide and
they're really thinking about new health
care plans you know that are gonna be
more than just you know on the margins
but to really rethink the whole health
care system other questions well one
thing I'll give the audience a moment to
think about this you touched on China
and you're talking about Walmart I mean
it was another fascinating part of your
book and I guess some subsequent
articles that I I read and in this
context of business having to rethink
itself you're thinking about what the
labor what labor looks like in
unionization looks like in China and
Walmart going to China
how Walmart is having and other or
businesses are having to change their
way of thinking I was wondering if you
could touch on that a little bit you
know I should talk about you know how I
think about China which will date me but
I remember this but America had a
Sputnik moment where all of a sudden
this country we knew nothing about you
know shot a satellite into space that
all of a sudden America woke up and said
oh my god we have a real competitor here
in ways that we never imagined an
America rallied we rallied as a country
you know we put people into science and
technology we invested in our future and
it was a good moment for America the
2008 Beijing Olympics are going to be a
Sputnik moment but people have never
been to China they're not going to
believe that you you have a country
where half of the construction half of
the concrete that was poured in the
world last year was poured in China some
people get around and they say the
national bird of China is going to be
the crane the construction crane because
everywhere you go you see that we had
65,000 Intel science fair finalists last
year we were very proud of
a record number in America China had six
million 90% of all the scientists in the
world will come from the Asian Pacific
region by 2010 you know you go to China
we have one beltway we think it's really
a problem to get around at they have six
you know beltway's because they keep
building out from the core cities
they're gonna build a hundred and ten
hotels in China in Beijing between now
and the Olympics I mean we don't just
get you know the competition we're
facing so I think it's gonna be that
moment where you hope American says we
have a real competitor they have a plan
we have no plan in America Team USA is
competing in a global economy we have no
plan we don't all we know is the results
that we're getting by doing the same
thing so it seems like we need to do
something different you know you go to
China and you know they actually have
very responsible labor laws on the books
they're obviously not enforced it's a
different kind of Union movement right
now and I think officially the Chinese
say they are a transmission belt the
union's transmission belt between the
party and the workers but it's changing
because they see Walmart they see Kara
for they see GE they see McDonald's
exiling companies that are coming there
with no intention you know really
raising wages they used to just run to
the government every time they had a
problem because everybody was a
state-owned enterprise and now they're
dealing with market capitalism and it's
not working for them and so they're
beginning to change and I keep saying I
think it's ironic that the first Walmart
I ever went into that had a union was in
Shenzhen China of all places but they
went out and they actually in a much
more traditional fashion organized this
union and I think you know if things
keep going 90% of all the foreign owned
enterprises will be unionized and shine
in the next you know eight or nine years
if not sooner and the question really is
is what do they do with it do they you
know just become a pawn for the employer
or do they actually represent the
interests of the workers and we're gonna
watch that evolution and we should pray
as American unionists that they're
successful and that they want to join up
with us to raise the wages of workers
everywhere because workers of the world
unite is not just this luck and it
happens to be the way we have to
approach the world if we're gonna change
things and the other thing I'd say about
this new global economy that we don't
appreciate is that you know all of a
sudden we have companies not countries
making the rules you know you look at
frame
and you look at Germany and all the
pressure that's put on some of their
employment regulations well Germany you
can't get rid of a fire or worker you
know France they wanted to make changes
in the employment well those were
companies putting pressure on countries
now we create a global trade global
companies you know global finance we
forgot to Kuwait global regulation we
forgot to Kuwait a global government
which will never have so now the
question is of the hundred largest
economies in the world 52 are companies
and 48 are countries and Walmart has a
higher sales than the GDP of Venezuela
even with the oil increases Ireland and
Singapore I mean this is just a
profoundly different world and so it
seems to me it's not just unions who
have to get together but NGOs
progressive government's because we're
now dealing with these huge economic
entities that are putting enormous
pressure on our countries and the
question is can we like the Sullivan
principles you know find a set of
agreements between NGOs and unions and
and responsible employers and
governments that really begin to say
that we expect of our global employers a
certain code of conduct and so far this
corporate social responsibility has been
very weak and it really hasn't served
its purpose but the Sullivan principles
serve a huge purpose of galvanizing
people to a set of outcomes that I think
we all need to work together to try to
find the same kind of principles for
this economy right I mean I think that
this concept of decent work and exactly
what you're talking about is really kind
of catching fire around the world and
it's important for us to find the
connectivity
with all the organizations all the
pieces that you talk about to try and
lift lift all those right are there
other questions I think we have one here
just one second
Garak Mitchell from the Mitchell report
Andy as I listen to as I listened to
this conversation the there's sort of
two thoughts that keep running through
my mind one is the notion of what's the
narrative for all of this how do we sort
of change the narrative and and the sort
of companion piece to that is it's clear
that business and labor have to work on
this together
but I'm interested to know what steps
you and SEIU have taken specifically to
you know enlarge the circle so that I'll
use the you know the most sort of
familiar example these days in American
politics communities of faith
faith-based organizations
evangelicals me know but it seems to me
that we know for example that the
environmental movement has made a very
concerted effort to do that
and I think they would say with with
fairly significant success that once
they really incorporated faith-based
institutions and evangelicals frankly in
particular it really began to make a
difference particularly up on the hill
so I'd be interested to know what you
have done and or what you're thinking
about on that yeah well first of all I
think we haven't done enough just to be
frank about it I think we see though you
know which cap has been very involved
with another allies have been involved
with a growing movement around the
minimum wage you know we have I think on
on five state ballots initiatives which
is a huge trend I think it's beginning
to focus you know at at one level on the
whole question of you know how is worker
to pay in America and the minimum wage
is kind of a stalking horse for that I
think some of the efforts you saw in
Chicago and Walmart tried to come to
town was another stalking horse in some
way of asking a question when people
come to town what kind of jobs are they
bringing with them and they expect you
know to become parts of our community
and I think we don't yet have the moral
you know tone to that I think a lot
faith-based you know organizations are
beginning to deal with that I talked to
Charles Steele head of the SCLC and you
begin to see the convergence because you
can't be a pastor in a church and that's
here your parishioners suffering you you
know you can't see people who are
thinking they're gonna work until
they're died and somehow think well you
know God's going to take care of all of
this later you know there are things
that people I think I believe you need
to be taking care of now and so I think
again the opportunity like globally for
convergence here around a different
narrative and the narrative I think is
simple it's the American dream for a
civil war two world wars natural
disasters recessions depressions forty
two different presidents you know we've
kept a dream alive that has made America
incredibly proud and our kids really
motivate everybody to do something so if
you love this country and you want to
keep the dream alive then I think people
of goodwill have to come together and
make a plan and understand we are in a
very very different economy I I like to
say last year the world produced more
transistors in grains of rice and the
transistors cost less last year we
produced an amount of manufacturing in a
day equal to the amount of manufacturing
the year I was born the Furby that
little kids toy has four times the
technology of the Apollo spaceship that
landed on the moon and while we've been
sitting here for all of you are getting
anxious that you haven't checked your
emails or blackberries you know while
we've been sitting here there been 3.7
billion emails sent in the world 84
billion will be sent this day now a lot
of Meryem I don't reach for it in panic
I mean this is just fundamentally such a
different economy this is before we even
get to the whole question of convergence
of watching television or you know
communicating or now we're doing bank
transactions on your cell phones I mean
this is just such a fast change in the
toffler's I think say it best which they
say we're building a new civilization in
front of our eyes and that no single
generation of people have ever witnessed
so much change and as I say in my book
there's only been three major economic
revolutions agricultural revolution
three thousand years industrial
revolution three hundred years this
revolution you know from
learn more from muscle work to mind work
from manufacturing to knowledge service
economy from national to international
30 years in one lifetime we are going to
see more change than people have ever
seen before and I don't think we've
grasped the implications of it whether
it's our global economy you know whether
it's our health care or retirement
system America needs a plan it's just a
different moment of history and in that
context we need to serve our country and
our children better Andy I think you're
absolutely right I mean some of the work
that we've done and looking and working
with the faith community there's so many
leaders of faith institutions that are
trying to provide you know clinics and
various forms of health care but they
realize you know we can do a lot and
that might be part of our mission but we
can't and shouldn't have to do it on the
scale that it should be provided for for
people who are desperately in need and
there's such a long term history
relationship between the faith community
and the Union community the unions
around child labor and a range of other
issues that I think there's a great
synergy there and we I should say this
because I'm not pandering because I but
it's really true I mean a cap has really
become a center you know for a whole
series of new organizations as well as a
whole new series of relationships that
they've centered and I I think we're all
better off for it because we're
beginning to have different kinds of
conversations from everything from
defense you know to the economy to
healthcare the faith-based organizations
to youth you know and I think it's just
enormous ly important now that we begin
to have an American conversation about
what people think about every day
because in Washington DC it's impossible
to convince people that people don't get
up every day and think about whether in
a red state or blue state I just
guarantee you they don't have a little
colored coat next to their bed to remind
them they think about what most
Americans think how am I going to get my
kid downstairs and out of the house on
time my mom's getting older and I gotta
go visit her or call her and see how
she's doing I got these bills on my desk
you know I have 121 percent of an
average American of my income is in debt
right now you know the whole country had
negative savings I mean people are
anxious you know they're incredibly
anxious for good reason they are working
harder they're being more productive and
they aren't sharing in the wealth and I
think you know it's a moment where we
need to come together as Americans and
we need the kind
institutions like Kappas both created
and brought together to find some common
ways of going forward well take one more
question
I'm Karen Anthony I work for the
administration for children and families
and this is kind of a I when I grew up
it seemed like everybody was in a union
and then all of a sudden it seemed like
nobody was in a union I guess my
question is how what what's the reaction
to younger workers when you when they're
approached about joining a union do they
have a perception that it's a bad thing
or or you just you know how does that
work yeah I mean I'd say you can read
Paul's and get all kinds of different
answers to this question I mean here's
the one thing we tend to have learned is
when employers step back and they let
workers make their own decisions workers
make good decisions sometimes they
choose unions and sometimes they don't
and for very good reasons in both cases
the problem is we have employers you
know when a someone quote the workers
decide to have a discussion about how to
change their life it becomes World War
three you know corporate jets fly in
with anti-union attorneys they you know
descend on people you start having these
private meetings people get threatened
there's all this pressure on you you
know why because you're Noons work they
actually make life a little bit better
for people that work in places and so
what's so sad is we now have a democracy
where that saying that you want to
change your life either becomes illegal
under the board because you're a
supervisor or more disgracefully you
know starts a whole epidemic of actions
that really say as a citizen I can't
really speak my mind and participate
there's a story about people picking
jurors in a case involving unions and
they were asking people their opinions
of unions and the judge said for the
first time in his life people wouldn't
answer the question it was so scared
that whatever they said was gonna get
back to their employer if they said
something good and at the same time they
knew they were sworn to tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but they
didn't want to commit perjury and so
they were having this hard time finding
a jury pool because people were
frightened and people should not be
frightened about changing their life in
America this is too great a country you
know
for people to get up who have every
anxiety about getting ahead and taking
care of their families and then they
have to go to work you know and be drug
to death simply because they want to do
something with their co-workers to
change their life America can do better
than that actually I think we can take
this one last question that we had over
here I'm sorry about that guys I got to
us a lot easier than the Colbert show
you've outlined a pretty tight tightly
reasoned argument for how the unions fit
into today's environment economic
political social environment would you
say that most other union leaders are on
the same page or do you think you're
maybe ahead of the game here well I may
be behind the game when when proof be
told overtime you know I'd say one of
the great things about forming change to
win is to get a group of union leaders
who want to learn together who don't
think we know the answers who appreciate
the world's change and appreciate we
have a responsibility to grow stronger
the be more independent in terms of our
political activity to build different
relationships with our employers we're
just beginning you know I don't know
where it ends you know I say to lots of
employers you can make our life a lot
easier because if we're successful it
only will breed more success so if we
can enter partnerships with you and
point to them and say you know this is
what comes from you know working
together and adding value then more
people will do it and I think that's the
question you know people we could be end
up walking away at a limb you know and
find no partners to dance with you know
fortunately we've begun to find some but
we need to find a lot more American
needs you know a different kind of
collaboration and I think we're
beginning to see a lots of unions begin
to rethink what they're doing now we
need to see the success that really
stimulates people to go further and take
greater risks well I want to thank Andy
coming to the center today to join us in
this converse